now a lot of attention has been focused  on the east of ukraine particularly  around the donbass region just tell us  what the latest situation is there at  the moment this is where the daily fight  is going on and it changes where the  priorities are it's russia's main effort  and russia's main effort has been around  the server donetsk area they're trying  to close at the moment as of today we're  hearing from isiam from the north down  to close this pocket to try and isolate  the ukrainian defenders in here um and  close them in and then defeat them and  then what we'll see the russians trying  to do is salami slice further bits off  until they've captured the whole of the  donbass region  philip thank you very much indeed